the very first boss fight in HiFi Rush
pits you against a giant robot that
wants to crush and eat you in order to
defeat this mechanical Titan you need to
wail on it with a guitar that's cobbled
together from scrap metal timing each of
your attacks to the up-tempo beat of
Nine Inch Nails is one million developer
Tango Gameworks is obviously known for
its Whimsy but it was previously
confined to a horror genre that HiFi
Rush most definitely does not belong to
instead Tango's latest is a surprisingly
vibrant Saturday morning cartoon of a
game capturing the spirit and electric
energy of a Dreamcast or GameCube title
in the best way possible it's tremendous
in almost every respect meshing its toe
tap in combat with genuine humor and a
massive helping of both confidence and
style
[Music]
foreign
at its core HiFi Rush is an interesting
mix between a character action game like
Devil May Cry or Bayonetta and a rhythm
game its melee action will feel
immediately familiar to anyone who's
well versed in the former as you use
your Flying V guitar to Pummel enemies
with combos consisting of both light and
heavy attacks juggle foes in the air and
Dodge out of the way of incoming danger
the best character action games are able
to lure you into a trance-like state as
you gradually become more proficient at
dispatching large groups of enemies yet
Hi-Fi Rush takes it a step further by
baking this rhythmic flow into its very
design you can still succeed by button
mashing your way to Victory but timing
your attacks to the beat of the game's
soundtrack lets you dish out increased
damage in clear areas in a much more
efficient manner enemies also attack and
move on the beat making each fight feel
like an improvised dance where you're
the main attraction
in order to help you find your Rhythm
the whole world of Hi-Fi Rush pulsates
with the beat of Whatever music is
currently playing providing you with
both Visual and audio cues for nailing
its timing elevators jerk up and down on
the beat computer lights blink with each
snare hit and the barriers that lock you
inside combat Arenas are made from
equalizers that move along with the
music the sound of mechanical gears
steam pipes and the thud of your own
footsteps even coalesce with the
soundtrack to create a harmonious noise
there are other optional visual cues you
can add for extra assistance like a
metronome but the basic timing concept
Remains the Same throughout even outside
of its slick and satisfying combat Hi-Fi
Rush is also refreshingly forgiving when
it comes to its rhythmic traits your
timing doesn't have to be consistently
perfect throughout every battle each
attack lands on the beat regardless so
it never feels like the game is
punishing your combat performance if you
miss time a string of attacks I spent
much of the game with around 60 accuracy
yet combat was still in utterly
enthralling blast this also solves one
of the biggest issues with rhythm games
typically these sort of games are
discordant if you're off beat either
your performance negatively impacts the
music or your chastised with the vexing
Out Of Tune clang to signal that you're
playing poorly in Hi-Fi Rush there isn't
any negative reinforcement to
potentially discourage you from
improving aside from a slight hit to
your score the challenge comes from it
being an action game rather than from it
being a rhythm game your timing has to
be exact to Parry incoming strikes for
instance but this is no different from
any other melee brawler you're actively
rewarded for being on beat with the
excited cheers of a crowd increased
damage and a higher likelihood of
achieving that coveted S rank
okay
[Music]
Hi-Fi Rush is at its best when you
Embrace and play along to the pulsing
soundtrack but doing so isn't essential
to your enjoyment this is partly because
Hi-Fi Rush's combat is also impressively
varied you have a plethora of combos at
your disposal both in the air and on the
ground with more unlocking as you
collect the gear pieces you need to
purchase them you can also call for
assistance from a few of the pals you
meet on your adventure each one named
after a different flavor of tea for some
reason peppermint one of your gun toting
companions uses a blaster to fire shots
that can disable enemy Shields the
game's musicality is omnipresent too
because she fires in triplets that match
the beat larger enemies don't react to
your attacks until you're able to break
their stun gauge leaving them vulnerable
to being stun locked and juggled now you
can do this by dealing enough damage to
crack it or by parrying their strikes
with expert timing there's a fair amount
go going on especially when you factor
in the different enemy types and
specific counters required to beat them
yet everything fits into this rhythmic
flow and never feels overwhelming Hi-Fi
Rush's boss battles in particular are a
highlight they're wildly inventive for
the most part with each one throwing a
unique challenge your way this is
usually where the licensed soundtrack
comes into play as well elevating these
back and forth clashes with tracks from
the likes of The Black Keys The Prodigy
and number girl the rest of the game
consists of original music that matches
the game's up-tempo Pop Rock theme and
there are plenty of catchy toe tappers
although I do wish there were slightly
more licensed songs Just because bopping
along and defeating enemies to familiar
beats has such a palpable impact even so
it is hard not to fall in love with
Hi-Fi Rush's slick aesthetic the
cel-shaded visuals are beautiful with
excellent animation and vibrant colors
that pop off the screen making it look
like a comic book come to life it oozes
Style aisle and there's a technical
proficiency to it as well not only does
it perform as smoothly as butter but the
seamless transitions from gameplay to 2D
animation to Blended 3D animation right
back to gameplay are phenomenal and it
does all of this without ever missing a
beat of the soundtrack there's a goofy
spirit and earnestness that emanates
from every part of Hi-Fi rush and this
playfulness prevents the dialogue from
ever feeling too cringy a style of
writing could have been nauseating in
the wrong hands but Tango manages to
make you fall in love with this ragtag
cast of characters including its Rogues
gallery of bosses protagonists try might
be an overconfident idiot but he
surprisingly endearing and the game is
genuinely funny without having to resort
to any irritating snark the story is
fairly straightforward as you try to put
a stop to an evil Mega Corporation but
there are some fun twists and turns
along the way too the only time HiFi
Rush falters is in the moments between
its kinetic combat the the game's
platforming is generally fine with
plenty of areas off the beaten path for
you to explore and find collectibles in
currency chai's jumping is a tad floaty
and imprecise but checkpoints are
incredibly lenient so this is never
really an issue the problem is that
these sections can drag on for far too
long at times when the combat is as good
as it is you just want to get back to it
but there are long stretches with
nothing but traversal to compound this
issue the game's environments are
aesthetically samey at various points
too with an overabundance of similar
looking labs and factories this isn't a
fatal flaw but some of the other
locations look incredible so it's a
shame that the same creativity isn't
utilized across all of its stages
despite these missteps HiFi Rush is a
tremendous game that's equal parts
explosive joyous and dripping with style
it feeds on the power of nostalgia by
evoking games like Jet Set Radio and
Beautiful Joe with its old school Vibes
and contagious energy but it's also
completely fresh and exciting in its own
right for as much as I adore horror
games and have enjoyed Tango's previous
output with The Evil Within series and
ghostwire Tokyo it is refreshing that
the studio hasn't been pigeonholed into
creating games within a singular genre
and can suddenly emerge one day with an
infectious Rhythm action game that is
sure to live long in the memory
foreign
[Music]